[Applauso]
grandi protagonisti della nostra vita
quotidiana sono i microbi quindi i virus
batteri funghi tutti quei microrganismi
che quotidianamente causano malattie
malattie che possono essere meno gravi
come un banale mal di testa mal di
pancia o malviventi poi ci sono malattie
più gravi
e poi ci sono le pandemie pandemie che
ci fanno una paura terribile per esempio
la pandemia dell'influenza della
spagnola una pandemia che nei primi
decenni del ventesimo secolo ha causato
milioni di morti fino a 100 milioni e
nei primi anni del ventesimo secolo
l'aspettativa di vita è diminuita a
causa di questo virus ci sono pandemie
che noi siamo riusciti a sconfiggere
poi ci sono pandemie che sono ancora
aperte sono pandemie che noi stiamo
ancora combattendo
per esempio la pandemia dell'aids
causata da un virus come la hiv che
conosciamo ma non conosciamo abbastanza
bene da sconfiggerlo se guardiamo la
mappa del nostro mondo vediamo che
quotidianamente in ogni angolo del mondo
ci sono sempre nuovi microbi che provano
entrare nella specie umana
e questi sono causa potenziale di nuove
pandemie pandemie che non conosciamo
non sappiamo come potranno finire poi ci
sono pandemie che possono essere causate
da microbi che conosciamo che pensavamo
di avere sconfitto completamente
pensavamo e di averli eliminati della
specie umana e pure ritorno né ci
troviamo di nuovo a dovere combatterli
quindi un rapporto molto intenso con i
microbi un rapporto quotidiano un
rapporto di guerre di continue battaglie
però oggi con voi vorrei guardare i
microbi da un altro punto di vista una
nuova luce e per fare questo
partirei da una molecola che è l'essenza
della nostra vita l'essenza di tutti gli
esseri viventi il dna se guardiamo
attentamente il dna in profondità il dna
è fatto di tanti mattoncini di tanti
nuclei tv che vanno a costruire delle
sequenze e le sequenze che formano il
nostro dna per la maggior parte sono
sequenze che noi conosciamo sequenze che
a cui noi siamo a familiari sequenze che
potremmo chiamare umane
però in realtà oltre a queste sequenze
quasi il 50 per cento del dna nostro è
fatto di sequenze di origine virale
quindi sequenza a noi estranee sequenze
che derivano dai microbi guardando
ancora più attentamente ben l'otto per
cento del nostro dna è fatto da sequenze
virali quindi da sequenze che
appartengono anche quelli virus che sono
circolanti che causano malattie ma la
cosa più sorprendente è che queste
sequenze di origine virale questi dna
virali che ci portiamo dietro non sono
dna completamente inerti inefficaci che
non fanno niente sono dna che hanno dei
ruoli fondamentali è un dna che servono
alla nostra vita alla nostra fisiologia
per farvi un esempio una proteina che
deriva da questo dna è una proteina che
serve a formare la placenta la placenta
niente di meno che quell organo che
serve a noi per essere mammiferi
potremmo quasi spingerci a dire che se
siamo mammiferi e grazie ai virus ai
microbi e poi pensate ai miliardi di
batteri che popolano il nostro intestino
questi batteri è stato dimostrato
recentemente che non servono soltanto al
nostro intestino ma servono a tante
altre cose serve al nostro sistema
immunitario serve al nostro sistema
nervoso
possiamo quindi dire che i microbi alla
fine non solo semplicemente dei nemici
ma ci conviviamo quotidianamente con i
microbi vorrei fare adesso un altro
passo avanti e raccontarvi un'altra
storia di collaborazione in questo caso
con i microbi esiste una disciplina
nella medicina che si chiama terapia
genica è una disciplina che prevede di
curare malattie genetiche andando a
portare una copia corretta del dna che
in alcune malattie e non funzionante al
mutato quindi portando questa coppia
corretta in persone che hanno malattie
genetiche possiamo curarle e pensate che
una delle tecniche più efficaci per fare
terapia genica sono i virus perché
possiamo utilizzare i virus le proprietà
dei virus che
sono potentissimi nel raggiungere le
nostre cellule sono potentissimi per
raggiungere il nostro dna e possiamo
quindi curarli curare queste persone
utilizzando i virus quando i virus lo
usiamo come navetta un esempio di un
grandissimo successo nella terapia
genica è una malattia che causa un
difetto a livello il sistema immunitario
è una malattia data da un gene per cui
se il gene non funziona il sistema
immunitario non è più in grado di
difendere le persone dai microbi i
bambini che nascono con questa malattia
vengono definiti bubble boys perché
devono essere confinati in ambienti
sterili lontani dai microbi nei decenni
i ricercatori hanno dimostrato che è
possibile curare questa malattia
utilizzando i virus come vettori come
navetta per portare la coppia corretta
di dna quindi un successo incredibile
data da una collaborazione tra uomini e
microbi
vi racconto la storia più recente una
storia di collaborazione tra uomini e
batteri
questa storia si chiama chris par
dovete sapere che anche batteri hanno il
loro battaglie quotidiane con i virus
devono continuamente difendersi da
attacchi virali i batteri hanno messo a
punto una tecnica potentissima per
difendersi dai virus hanno a
disposizione una molecola che è una
forbice molecolare questa forbice
molecolare i batteri la usano per
tagliare il dna dei virus quando questi
vanno invadere le loro cellule quindi
riescono a difendersi a tagliarla la
forbice molecolare è una molecola che i
ricercatori cercavano da anni per curare
malattie genetiche
perché se noi prendiamo la forbice
molecolare la portiamo nelle cellule
umane possiamo tagliare il dna nei punti
in cui vogliamo riportare il dna
funzionare in maniera corretta quindi
ricercatore qualche anno fa hanno preso
la molecola crispa l'hanno portata
dell'inter nel mall e dentro le cellule
umane e hanno dimostrato che questa
forbice molecolare di origine batterica
può funzionare per tagliare il dna nei
punti in quel dna non sta comportando
maniera corretta e anche qui i virus
navetta funzionano benissimo ci servono
per portare cristo hard dentro le
cellule che noi vogliamo curare
quindi la forbice molecolare può essere
programmata per andare nel punto voluto
tagliare la mutazione o addirittura
inserire delle sequenze corrette
questa notizia di questa molecola non
poteva lasciarmi indifferente
ho passato una carriera scientifica
studiare il virus nuove tecniche per
ingegnerizzare dna quindi alla notizia
di questa nuova molecola con il mio
laboratorio messi subito a lavorare e
grazie a un team di ricercatrici
brillantissimi e brillanti ricercatori
siamo riusciti a lavorare con questa
tecnica dimostrando che è potente nel
poter andare a correggere dna ci siamo
accorti tuttavia all'inizio che questa
molecola oltre a fare il taglio che
doveva fare previsto nel punto faceva un
sacco di altri errori
beh c'era d'aspettarselo una proteina di
origine batterica non abituata a
muoversi dentro cellule umane quindi ci
siamo messi subito al lavoro
l'abbiamo migliorata l'abbiamo resa
perfetta e precise al punto tale da
tagliare solo il punto mutato quindi ci
siamo avvicinati alla possibilità di
utilizzare questa molecola in clinica
ma oltre questo abbiamo fatto un passo
avanti abbiamo pensato che oltre a
ottimizzare la tecnica potevamo
cominciare a mettere appunto delle
tecniche per curare malattie genetiche
ci siamo concentrati su una malattia che
è una delle più frequenti tra levati e
genetiche alla fibrosi cistica è una
malattia che va a colpire diversi organi
in particolare le vie aeree ed è molto
grave diminuisce fortemente
l'aspettativa di vita alle persone che
ne sono affette non vivono più di 40
anni
quindi abbiamo preso cristo e abbiamo
dimostrato che con chris bar si può
eliminare la mutazione e si può un
giorno andare a curare malattie che
soffrono da questa malattia come noi ci
sono tantissimi i laboratori al mondo
che stanno lavorando su questa
tecnologia e ci stanno lavorando sia per
migliorarla per renderla utilizzabile in
clinica ma anche per mettere a punto
nuove strategie di medicina
alla tecnologia che ad oggi si pensa di
utilizzarla su individui adulti ma in un
futuro possiamo utilizzarla anche a
livello embrionale e possiamo prevedere
di eradicare malattie genetiche in
maniera tale che i bambini possano
nascere senza malattie che sono
devastanti
quindi stiamo vivendo un vero e proprio
cambiamento paradigmatico della medicina
in parallelo la chirurgia classica
possiamo dire che abbiamo a disposizione
i nuovi strumenti per un tipo di
chirurgia che va a livello del dna un
bisturi genomico che ci permetta di
andare a correggere le mutazioni in
maniera tale da evitare che malattie che
non sono curabili possano diventare
improvvisamente curabili quindi un
cambiamento nel futuro che probabilmente
abbiamo ottenuto abbiamo ottenuto
sicuramente grazie ai microbi quindi
tutti i microbi che popolano il nostro
alla nostra vita che ci sono intorno
sono diventano una grande risorsa di
strumenti per la medicina del futuro di
un futuro prossimo di un futuro che non
è lontano ed è vicino qua del 2039
grazie a tutti